the reprie was nice while it lasted but  gas prices are quickly going up again  yeah and that spike is being felt worse  in the Western United States here is a  look at National averages as you can see  averages in Nevada we're paying two  dollars a gallon more than states in the  blue our current average is five dollars  and 32 cents a nearly 40 Cent jump in  the last week There's a combination of  reasons for the current rise first being  the war in Ukraine which is limiting the  oil supply globally secondly States plan  on holding the winter blend back until  November winter Blends are cheaper  because gas is less likely to evaporate  and the third reason is due to planned  and unplanned maintenance on Western  refineries maintenance is scheduled  around this time because demand usually  decreases except that has not been the  case for the western states Western  wildfires have further complicated  matters as well